hello Steve here in the desert once
again escaping the rains of Vancouver
today I want to talk about what to do
when you have that block the anxiety
block that prevents you from speaking I
had a number of people ask me that
question I have it everyone has it to
varying degrees
I remember in Vancouver before coming
down here I went to the barber my barber
Vadim the Russian speaking Ukrainian
barber whenever I go there and I always
like to have my hair cut there because
we speak Russian and so I were totally
into our Russian discussion an in walks
one of his customers a Japanese girl 25
year old girl who's been living in
Vancouver for a few years and so he Dean
says speak to her in Japanese so I
switched to Japanese and of course to
have a conversation Japanese but very
common words in Japanese that I'm used
to having no trouble recalling and all
of a sudden they went in my brain went
to Russian I couldn't get a bite
therefore gamma Thomas not Thomas there
was a vlog and I've had this before I
was in I was in Vienna on my way to
Romanian I've been studying Romanian and
I was at a dinner and there was some
Czech people there and despite my year
of studying Chuck I couldn't get a word
of check out I was totally blocked and
the more I tried to speak Czech the more
I couldn't and so this happens so what
do you do well in those cases for
example Japanese is not a big issue I
have no trouble switching to Japanese
and if once got into the conversation of
course I was finding all the words that
I needed to find Czech I don't speak as
well I would have to spend an hour to
listening to check getting back into
that Czech environment because it's not
only to give your brain more practice
with the language but it's also that the
environment matters if I'm with with
Vadim and it's a Russian environment and
all of a sudden you know Japanese enters
the picture it's it's a little more
difficult I'm in a Romanian environment
in fact at this reception there were
other Romanians I was practicing the
Romanian that I've been learning and all
of a sudden is a Czech person I just
couldn't switch so that the the move
manners it's also often a matter of how
you relate to the people you're talking
to some people I've noticed this I speak
certain a language that I'm learning or
I don't speak so well I speak it better
with certain people than with other
people because it creates a sort of a
pleasant you know resonance within me so
all of these things affected and so
therefore you take it one step further
if you feel anxiety if you feel you're
in a situation or you're afraid to speak
or any negativity is going to impede
your ability to speak well so we have to
recognize this and so as some people
because they feel anxious about how they
sound or how they're going to do or
because they want to they want so much
to perform well they that puts pressure
on them and then they don't perform well
or in fact they do perform well but they
think they don't perform well all of
this anxiety is very negative so my
advice to people is first of all make
sure that you invest a lot of time and
effort in lots of listening and reading
build up your comprehension build up
your vocabulary so that you're confident
that you're going to understand what
people say because if you don't
understand what they're saying that only
adds to the anxiety so that's one thing
but the second thing is if you feel this
anxiety you have to recognize that it is
in in a way it's not real it's a form of
obsessive compulsive behavior it's like
people who feel they have to wash their
hands every five minutes it's it's a
pattern in your brain that is telling
you that you should feel nervous and you
should feel uptight and all of this
prevents you from retrieving words that
you have in your brain and it prevents
you from speaking as fluently as you
could so there I have mentioned in a
previous video on several occasions in
fact the work of Jeffery Schwartz who
wrote a book called the mind and the
brain where he points out that the mind
our determination and our willfulness
can influence how the brain works and
when he has clients patients with
obsessive compulsive behavior rather
than using drugs
he has a whole treatment which is based
on getting these patients to recognize
that this behavior pattern is not them
it's it's something that the brain is
doing but that they can in fact get the
brain to stop doing and so you have to
save yourself if I can reduce the
tension and the pressure and the anxiety
and then I'm going to do better so
therefore every time I communicate in
the language I should say good I
communicated not worried about what I
missed or forgot her worried about how I
sounded it simply said I did well I did
as well as I was able to do and if I
continued speaking and listening and
reading I will only get better I will
not get worse in other words try to
remove the anxiety now that sounds
easier said than done
many people will continue to feel this
blog and I guess you just have to train
yourself recognize this is not me I
don't have to feel this anxiety I can
instead of feeling the anxiety I can bit
by big bit recognize that I'm doing well
and if I take some of the anxiety away
I'll even start doing better and so that
I will continue to improve so really
that's the only advice I can give
I don't feel while I have situations
just like if I'm at a party and someone
walks in and I can't remember the name
the more I try to think that person's
name the less likely I am to remember
the name because I've created this
anxiety so you have to remove the
anxiety now how you go about doing that
again recognize that it's something you
can do like so much in language learning
your own will and determination can
influence how the brain performs how
well it learns and how well it uses the
language that's my advice I hope that
answers the question thank you for
listening